i kylo Ren hello Chris Stockman I've
been waiting for this day for a long
time I'm just working on my review for
the last Jedi if you wouldn't mind oh
cool yeah Ryan's a good guy even though
his name is spelled a little weird for
the game we all are so it doesn't matter
so you ready to die I'm here kylo we'll
do it we'll do it right here actually I
have a surprise for you
I'm gonna show you the dark side oh hi
Chris
ah Oh Mike Tommy how you gonna review
the room Tommy I'm trying to work on my
review the last Jedi need to stop coming
here and asking me what I think of the
room you know I don't like the room oh
come on you're reviewing last Jaya who
cares about that people care about room
okay okay I like it it's good it's
really good and you made a great film
okay you don't want to review we're
gonna play club on outcome no I don't
want to play football with you Tommy
there's a million other sports in the
galaxy football is not the only sport
that's out there other things have you
ever heard of basketball or baseball
okay I guess for playing football
the last Jedi is in theaters now and
this is gonna be a spoiler filled review
I'm gonna be talking about all different
types of plot details if you didn't see
it in the title please be aware we're
gonna get into spoilers here
you've been warned thank you so much to
my good friend Matthew Brando for
portraying kylo Ren slash Tommy Wiseau
in that opening skit Aaron J Morton for
the incredible music and Kevin a yacht
for helping me with the CGI lightsaber
effects
you guys are all the MVPs and I thank
you so much let's talk about spoilers
for the last Jedi which I got to see a
second time tonight so like I said in my
original review I had a great time with
the last Jedi but it wasn't flawless it
had some serious pacing issues in the
first act and some storylines that just
didn't work for me so let's get the
negatives out of the way first and talk
about things that I did not like about
the last Jedi and kind of switched up a
little bit because I talked about all
the things I loved already and I
couldn't really get too deep into my
negatives because I didn't want to
provide any spoilers there's a fairly
solid argument to be made about how much
merit a spoiler-free Star Wars review
really has anymore because you have to
try so hard to not ruin anything for
people which is very necessary I think
but sometimes the review itself can
suffer as a result
you're basically attempting to traverse
an entire review without ruining
anything for anybody and it can be
difficult with big movies like this so
let's talk about the kanto bite sequence
of the last Jedi because this entire bit
should not be in this movie I said in my
original review the storyline with Finn
Andros they go to a place and I'm going
to talk too much about it but it's sort
of this casino world like it just felt
like Earth there were some exotic
creatures that were there and some kind
of Star Wars C imagery but for the most
part it just felt like a casino with a
lot of interesting looking folk and it
just it was like the film halts and
becomes this sort of slapstick comedy
inside this place and they have to all
of a sudden free these animals and then
there's a message about animal cruelty
that's kind of thrown in there and this
entire sequence just doesn't work in
fact one of my lifelong friend
I saw it with tonight he loves Star Wars
just as much as I do and afterwards he
looked over and he was like oh I really
love that movie but you know what I did
not like that gambling thing and I was
like thank you because it just it tanks
the pacing of the first act it also
introduces Benicio Del Toro's character
which I didn't even mention in my
original review because nobody really
knew too much about what he was playing
he plays sort of a Mack from Kingdom of
the Crystal Skull like character this
guy who betrays people and sometimes
he's on their side and sometimes he
betrays them it didn't work on Kingdom
of the Crystal Skull most things didn't
work in that movie and it doesn't really
work here del Toro is a great actor and
he does a lot with this character to
make him feel unique and he's a likable
presence but the character just does
nothing in this movie he helps them get
there he's this codebreaker they need
but he doesn't really add much of any
weight to the story it's almost like the
entire film takes a detour to find this
guy for him to eventually just betray
them in my review when I said there were
sequences that reminded me of the
Phantom Menace documentary with Lucas
agonizing over the fact that he has
included story elements that he can't
remove because they're all
interconnected this entire canto bites
sequence feels like that to me at least
if I was the guy who made this film I
would be sitting there thinking man this
really shouldn't be here but we can't
take it out because it connects to
everything else it's got to be there and
for the rest of the runtime you're sort
of left wondering what really was the
point of that until the final shot of
the film when you see this young boy
that Rose gave the Rebel Alliance ring
to use the Force to get his broom and
start sweeping and he looks up to the
stars
so there's multiple reasons that this
could happen this could be just the
message that hope is always going to be
there there's always going to be force
sensitive people Luke Skywalker the last
Jedi isn't the last Jedi there's always
going to be more even beyond Rey or its
leading into something that's going to
happen in 9 Oh
it's leading into Ryan Johnson's
proposed trilogy so who knows what's
gonna happen with this little boy but it
is intriguing
so that's easily the aspect of this film
that bugged me the most it just it feels
like it tanks the pacing of the entire
picture it's one of the reasons why I
struggle with this and force awakens
because a lot of people enjoyed the
force awakens a lot of people hated it
and a lot of people loved it it's one of
those strange Star Wars movies where
there is no vast majority because
critics really liked it it has a high
rating on IMDB for the most part people
I talked to liked the force awakens but
there's plenty of people who don't
because it was too similar to other
films with the last Jedi it has a lot of
similarities to other things you have
Rey being shown the fleet being
destroyed Snoke is like look at this the
fleet's being destroyed harkening back
to the Emperor showing Luke the fleet
being destroyed in Return of the Jedi it
has a scene with Yoda which was amazing
and I loved it it was puppet Yoda and it
was very funny I loved how Luke was like
it's the ancient texts I can't believe
it's the ancient texts and they're gone
and Yoda is like have you read them page
turners they're not I loved stupid drunk
hilarious Yoda I I missed that Yoda
we'll talk a little bit more about Yoda
and Luke soon but there are comparisons
there
it has Rey finding a deep dark place
where she sees some sort of vision like
in the Empire Strikes Back obviously
she's being trained by Luke and a
desolate area there are similarities as
I said in my original review there's
story beats that are similar but it's
tough to ask the eighth film and a
franchise to be entirely new this is
definitely a film that has a fresh voice
it's a film that has sequences that
we've never seen in a Star Wars film
excellent direction of lightsaber scenes
for instance one of my favorites in the
entire saga is now this incredible
action scene with the Praetorian guards
after kylo Ren murders Snoke which I
found immensely satisfying because Snoke
to me was one of the weaker elements of
the force awakens and here he's an evil
old guy
in some ways all of these Snoke theories
have basically been proven false because
he's kind of a giant red herring unless
they do something with him in nine or
about his backstory because in reality
he was just sort of a placeholder for
kylo to take hold of the first order
which I loved because Adam driver as
kylo Ren is one of my favorite villains
of recent years his performance is
magnetic this is a fabulous actor and he
gives such a damaged and conflicted
portrayal of this character that every
time he's on screen I am just drawn to
him and it's not just the beautiful
direction and the fast-paced action of
this lightsaber battle that made me
enjoy it so much it's the fact that the
matically something is going on because
you see kylo kill Snoke and then you're
thinking to yourself is he going to side
with Rey are they gonna become a team
and there's there's stuff going on in
this battle more than just slicing and
dicing and so you feel kind of more
invested in it as a result and
afterwards you realize that kylo is
hoping to side with array and start
their own Empire and Rey obviously has
different thoughts on this and so
they're still at odds but they're both
working towards each other trying to get
inside each other's heads let's talk
about the force in the last Jedi because
they play with things that they've never
really gone into in a Star Wars film
before and I am positive that it will
anger Star Wars fans because there are
specific things that happen like for
instance the force connection that kylo
and Ray have were suddenly they're
within each other's environments and
they can feel each other and see each
other and in one case kylo actually
brings back something from where rey was
in the rain he wipes his head and
there's rain water there on his glove
and that's the first hint that it's
possible to physically transfer matter
through the force plane now some people
aren't gonna like this and they're gonna
call bullshit on it because especially
at the
and when Luke shows up and fights kylo
Ren and he realized that he is
projecting his image and he has given
Leia that piece of jewelry those are
those beads that were from a Millennium
Falcon and he has also changed his
appearance his hair is like it used to
be it's shorter and his hair is darker
he has made himself looking younger he's
projecting himself the way kylo perhaps
remembers him and perhaps the way Leia
last saw him so that's kind of
interesting why did he do that was it to
soften the blow of Leia seeing how old
and disheveled he is was he doing that
specifically for her I think maybe he
was I don't know I I thought it was kind
of sweet let's talk a little bit about
that sequence because on second viewing
I noticed something pretty awesome that
is really good direction Luke never
leaves the red marks underneath the salt
I looked on his feet every single time
he moved or slid around he never leaves
you know those skid marks of red kylo
does every single time that's a really
great little thing that that Ryan
Johnson put into this film and it holds
up on second viewing there's no cheating
there but I think people are really
gonna be bugged by this because they've
never seen the force used that way and
I'll admit the first time I saw it I was
a little taken aback I was kind of like
okay is this gonna be a thing like can
Jedi do this I am perfectly fine with it
I cannot wait for thirty years from now
when kids are watching this movie and
they don't give a shit about what
critics are saying in the year 2017
these kids don't care what I'm saying or
what anybody else is saying or any of
these complaints that people might have
they're just enjoying this moving going
Wow Jedi can do that okay because like
for us when I was a kid and I watched
Return of the Jedi on VHS I never
questioned things like that I just
accepted it because that was part of
canon now it was part of the world and I
like the fact that this movie has
deepened the mythology of the Jedi it
has shown that there are other levels
other things that Jedi can do
I mean imagine if in Dragon Ball Z Goku
became a Super Saiyan and after that
that was just it there's no more
exploration there's no more deepening of
the saiyan mythology there's no more two
three four Super Saiyan God there should
always be more to explore with these
stories especially with one as vast as
star wars and I am fine
with the introduction of new things the
force can do this isn't something that
bugged me this is a movie about people
who can use this mystical power to lift
rocks and stuff I mean they even joke
about that in this movie I like the idea
that Luke basically uses everything he
has left to do this one last-ditch
effort and then he gives himself up to
the force or does he does he die because
of what he did is what he did so
impossibly difficult that it kills him
or did he choose to die in this moment
and at peace gave himself up to the
force I'm gonna say at peace he gave
himself up to the force he obi-wan did
sort of speak and I really thought that
was really powerful especially the WYD
of him looking at the Suns which harkens
back to that shot the beautiful shot and
Tatooine and a new hope I thought this
was a gorgeously directed movie let's
talk a little bit about Luke Skywalker
because Mark Hamill has very openly said
he disagreed with a lot of the choices
in the script for one the second he
takes his lightsaber he throws it behind
him over a cliff now I can genuinely say
that I did not expect that at all
there's a lot of things in this film
that I didn't expect and Luke's
curmudgeon II behavior is one of them
let's talk a little bit about Luke and
Yoda in the prequels Yoda is this
wizardly sage person he's this presence
that's to be respected people go to him
for advice
he seems a level-headed when he loses
everything and all of the Jedi are
killed in Revenge of the Sith he goes in
hiding for quite some time and kind of
becomes a little curmudgeon II and silly
he still has his Jedi ways about him as
you learn in Empire Strikes Back but
he's totally different all of a sudden
this isn't just
because of the the time swapping of when
they actually filmed these movies this
is clearly the story George Lucas wanted
for Yoda when it comes to Luke it's
almost the same
Luke was this character who wanted to
learn about the force and believed in it
and he felt hope but after what happened
with kylo Ren he said I can't deal with
this anymore I feel responsible for this
he felt responsible for what he did to
his sister and to Han and he went into
exile just like Yoda and became a
different person just like Yoda and this
film has a kind of thrilling argument
that I've thought about for many years
for the fact that the Jedi don't always
do everything so right and Luke feels
like maybe it's time for this to pass
because we suck and I love that because
it's unexpected which is something that
a lot of fans have asked for in Star
Wars a lot of fans have asked for the
unexpected and this movie does have a
lot of surprises and things that take
the series and new interesting
directions let's talk a little bit about
Leia we finally for the very first time
actually get to see her using the force
she had a connection with Luke and the
Empire Strikes Back and she found him in
Cloud City but he or she nearly dies and
uses the force to bring herself back to
the ship people are gonna say she's
flying she's not flying she's basically
I've said this for years Jedi should be
able to fly if they can control things
around them why shouldn't they be able
to control the pressure that basically
would float them upwards if they can
float a rock they should you know in
some way control the plane around them
to allow them to float around a little
bit and obviously they can jump
extremely high so they should be able to
float a little bit longer so I honestly
really liked this idea that Leia is
slightly more powerful perhaps more
attuned to what she can do and I gotta
say I have no idea what they're going to
do in episode 9 because at the end of
this film she's on a Millennium Falcon
with Rey
I have no idea what they're going to do
I mean they've said they won't resurrect
her with CGI which I'm very grateful for
but aside from the opening crawl
literally saying
Princess Leia has died hope is lost all
they can maybe do is have the knowledge
that she's on a ship and the ship blows
up or something I have no idea what
they're going to do it's it's a very
interesting situation a very unfortunate
situation there's one arc in this film
that I thought was pretty unique and
that's Poe's arc he's a hotshot he's a
flyboy Laura Dern's character talks
about this a lot how many times in
movies have we seen that one character
who's running around trying to convince
everyone they're doing it wrong and he
knows the best way to do it you guys are
doing it wrong you guys gonna kill us
all can't listen to me and that
character is always right you're always
on his or her side because they're that
lone person that you side with and you
know they're right and they end up doing
the right thing and everyone has to go
I'm so sorry you were right all along
this movie has a very different way of
going about this poe is positive that
what he is saying is right they need to
attack or they need to change their
course or something he's ready to
basically take over from Laura Dern in
command and he tries to do a mutiny but
you find out that he was basically going
about it the wrong way there's a great
arc with him because in the beginning he
gets in trouble for trying to blow up
this dreadnought when Leia tells him to
you know get out of there he has this
this kind of violent side that feels he
has to do this now and defy leadership
this comes back later when you realized
that there was always a plan he almost
ruined it and he has to take a step back
and this all comes back into play for
him at the end of the film when Luke
steps out on the battlefield
and stalls long enough for them to
escape and pose the one who realizes
this because he realizes in this moment
okay we don't always have to blow shit
up sometimes we can stealth this bitch
and we can save more lives that way and
I thought that was a really nice arc
let's talk about a few moments in
particular I really liked I loved r2
showing Luke the old message of
Leia and Luke was like that's a cheap
shot great little callbacks like that
that serve to deepen a moment or a scene
not just like hey remember this thing
it's it serves to enliven that moment
and create more character emotion and I
really love that I also just I loved
Luke carrying a giant fish that he
killed it reminded me of Goku running
away with a big fish after killing it
there's a lot of anime inspired imagery
and the Jedi are treated almost like
samurai I think there's a lot of
inspiration here from Kurosawa and how
he directed there's some beautiful
applied shots and some stuff that just
really leaps off the screen and I could
be wrong but I've seen it twice now and
I look for the second time when kylo has
his mask in his hand on the elevator and
he smashes it into the wall and we see a
close-up of the mask for a split second
and I swear it looks like the mask is
crushed into Vader's viscid
I could be wrong but it looked like that
for a split second to me so it's really
just the rose and Finn storyline and the
canto bites stuff I feel like they
should have really shrunk that or found
a quicker way to do things and given a
lot more time to Luke and Rey on the
island that would have very much so
benefited this story and it would have
given more emotion to the Luke and Rey
storyline which I think could also have
improved the film but it almost feels
like it had to be in there for that
final shot with this boy because
Johnson's planning something with that
kid and it just feels like the biggest
detour to have this kid introduced
randomly you know it just didn't work
for the film and I said in my original
review that this sequence on Kanto bite
is necessary for you to care about stuff
with Finn and Rose later and that was
that she kisses him and I didn't give a
shit in fact Finn is about to sacrifice
himself and I thought that moment was so
powerful her rescuing him and then
saying like this is how we win by saving
those we love or whatever instead of
fighting I was like that's cheesy that
that's just cheesy to me that doesn't
know like if Finn had sacrificed himself
I would have thought it was really
powerful
her blasting in there I'd actually kind
of ruined the moment a little bit to me
and I didn't feel a thing really
emotionally when they kissed in fact
something I noticed is that I'm pretty
sure Finn didn't really either because
he was kind of like oh oh that's you
just kiss me okay I feel like he's a
little more thinking about ray yeah cuz
he he wants to immediately it's the
first thing he says I think that's what
he says is Ray when he wakes up in the
pod and as soon as he sees her he wants
to hug her and embrace her and he's
thinking about her it's one of the first
things he asked is where's ray and I
feel like Rose is thinking more about
Finn than Finn is her so there could be
a bit of a love triangle thing going on
in nine I hope that's not too
insufferable
it's just that Rose Finn storyline that
really tanks the pacing for me and other
than that I think this is a extremely
exciting and unexpected Star Wars movie
with a great unique original vision and
some of the best action of the entire
saga I had a really good time with this
movie and it's positioning characters in
a very intriguing way I love that kylo
is just the unhinged leader now there's
nobody holding him back I can't wait to
see what they do with him at nine I like
the dynamic that they're creating with
Ray and kylo I think that's one of my
favorite things so far in these two
films one of the things I promised was
that I would tell you what my ranking is
now that I've seen it twice the thing is
this is in some ways a more original
film in the force awakens it's a film
that sometimes has more powerful and
incredible Star Wars moments where the
highs are just so high but the force
awakens is a better paced film there's
really a minute for me anyway that drags
this film has about 20 minutes that drag
and so I think I like the force awakens
a hair more and so this is my official
ranking of all the films I've included
the silly dumb CG animated Clone Wars
movie in there as well guys thank you so
much as always for watching I hope you
enjoyed the last Jedi and if you didn't
you know it happens it's a Star Wars
movie we've all experienced Star Wars
movies
we didn't quite like this one I think is
a different and unique one and I had a
good time with it it retains a lot of
the emotion the first one did force
awakens and I'm glad to see that guys
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]